family and friends of a missing
University of Utah student are pleading
for information about her mysterious
disappearance shortly after taking a
lyft ride mackenzie looook was last seen
one week ago today CTM lead national
correspondent David Beck know was
following the story David what do we
know about how all this happened well
last Monday Mackenzie Lewis family says
she landed at the Salt Lake City
International Airport after attending
her grandmother's funeral in California
she took a lift from the airport to an
address in North Salt Lake her family
and friends say since then the 23 year
old hasn't been seen or heard from I've
never met a person that doesn't like
Mackenzie she is the sweetest and most
genuine Julianne collie says she has
felt lost ever since her best friend
Mackenzie looook disappeared the pair
met in college at the University of Utah
where looook is studying kinesiology
Kali says they hit it off from the start
it's not like her to go off the grid and
if she did then she would tell me looook
was last heard from around 1:00 a.m. on
June 17th when she texted her mom to say
her flight landed safely at Salt Lake
International Airport from there police
say she ordered a lift to an address in
North Salt Lake but Kali says looook
didn't live in North Salt Lake and she
doesn't know why she went there her
parents reported her missing three days
later lyft told CBS News in a statement
the safety of its community is
fundamental and it is actively assisting
law enforcement with their investigation
lyft says there were no irregularities
in the ride that looook took and that it
ended at the destination she entered in
the app and the driver continued to take
other customers immediately after
dropping her off I still call and text
her hoping that she'll pick up or she'll
respond
since disappearing she's not had any
activity on social media and loic's
friends and sorority sisters have been
passing out flyers in Salt Lake City
hoping anyone with information is going
to come forward I would do anything to
get her back and honestly I would trade
her places and a heartbeat just to know
that she's safe
so the Salt Lake City Police Department
says lyft and the driver have cooperated
with the investigation the department
says it has not discovered anything at
this point that would lead them to
believe that looook has been
in any way loic's father told our Salt
Lake City affiliate KUTV that they are
working to get subpoenas for her cell
phone records because that could help
them figure out some news you know they
haven't revealed the address she went
they have not know otherwise we try and
go knock because they keep saying why
can't we just knock on the door what
happened right now we don't know we'll
keep working it today and the mystery is
why was she going there all right David
thanks